we get to talk about a different
football league and Peter I don't know
that Skeptical is the right word I I'm
just I'm careful with new football
leagues because new football leagues and
evitable II become failed football
leagues and I don't want to assume that
the XFL is gonna fail but I don't want
to get invested in and emotionally I
don't want to fall in love with the XFL
and then have the XFL go away I've had
my heart broken enough times by football
leagues that I kind of liked that went
away with that set and I also kind of
liked the fact that we can really
maintain full and complete independence
here we have no affiliation no
association no broadcasting relationship
with the XFL so we can say what we truly
believe the way we want to say it
without any phone calls coming from
Vince McMahon or all of her luck now all
that said and I went into it wanting to
not really like it wanting to not tie up
six hours on a Saturday and six hours on
a Sunday I kind of liked it now I didn't
love it they need star players and
they're not gonna thrive the way they
could without Johnny Manziel or Trevor
Lawrence or whatever college guys are
all the rage pay him fire maybe or maybe
for you maybe Curley Lloyd that would be
another one somebody who would get us to
tune in it can't just be the uniforms it
can't just be the really cool kick-off
formation which I think the NFL needs to
adopt we'll talk about that in a minute
but Peter if this league is gonna thrive
it needs star power and all due respect
PJ Walker Jordan Tom ooh that's not the
star power that's gonna get people to
tune in it's not when you look at the
stars that make the NFL go you're not
gonna be anywhere close to that in the
XFL and they need to spend the money to
attract star players and they're out
there if they really want to do it yeah
I would disagree with you on that Mike I
think that would be basically you know
that would be like the kid is hungry the
kid is screaming let's shut him up and
give him a candy bar because that'll
shut him up just shut him up for a
little while but he's gonna scream again
soon in my opinion the reason that these
leagues don't work usually is that they
don't have their eye
the long haul they say we need to get
that real quick sugar buzz you know like
the XFL in 2001 yeah I will never forget
I was at that first game in Las Vegas
writing for Sports Illustrated and Dick
Ebersol Vince McMahon the day before the
game this was a major major media event
everybody was so excited about it they
had a huge TV rating on Saturday night
primetime TV
and then next week they'll and the week
after that they landed on the cover of
Sports Illustrated and and you know it
didn't last that league's dead after one
year the way that you'd do this is not
to take guys who flamed out in the NFL
like Johnny Manziel I mean if you are if
you are staking your future on guys like
Johnny Manziel you're gonna die and
again I totally agree with you being
very very equivocal equivocal about
basically you know the future in this
league all these leagues look great at
the beginning all these leagues have
great optimism I read all the quotes
from the ESPN Talent before the first
game and here's why this league is gonna
last and why it has a great chance and
and I just said man they're not you we
can't we have to assume that look
they're televising the games so all due
respect any of this stuff from ESPN and
Fox is corrupted by the reality and this
is fair for us to say it they have the
game so you have to view it through that
prism right they want it to be
successful they're trying to speak it
into existence and I'm just skeptical
because I don't want to get burned
listen the the greatest thing that
happened this weekend I thought is that
if you looked at that game in Washington
on Saturday that looked like an event
that was cool and that people wanted to
be at you know the stadium there and it
was in a 20,000 seat soccer stadium
which was 85% full and it was an
enthusiastic crowd that is what they
need to do this league should not be
playing in MetLife Stadium it looks
awful it looks like nobody cares
they said okay where else are we gonna
play well I don't know you played
Rutgers play somewhere else I mean but I
just don't think you should play in a
place that you know except on views like
this okay we're all you're seeing is
football you know it anything other than
a camera from the top of the stadium you
know looking down it just it just
doesn't look like anybody cares so I I
mean but but again in general this game
this team these teams will have a chance
if people just simply do not get greedy
Peter you're absolutely right about how
it looks on TV all four of the games had
between 17 and 18,000 people in
attendance but the DC defenders hosting
the Seattle dragons felt like a bigger
deal because this stadium felt full the
game last night between Dallas and who
did Dallas play the st. Louis battle
Hawks the only road team to win this
weekend yeah it the entire twenty into
one eight when you have constant shots
of the upper deck empty and the lower
deck spotty eventually you ask yourself
why am i watching this this is why the
NFL had a blackout rule for all those
years the NFL wants full stadiums this
is why for Super Bowl 1 before it was
even called the Super Bowl they took all
the people at the Coliseum and scrunched
them in so when they had shots of the
stands they would look full instead of
spotting all the way around if it feels
like a big deal we think it's a big deal
the Saturday game between Seattle and DC
felt like a big deal even though it was
roughly the same number of people
because they have a stadium that holds
20,000 people you're absolutely right
you know Seattle is gonna be flying it's
CenturyLink Field what's that going to
look like now they've supposedly had an
uptick in ticket sales since the
Seahawks season ended but they're not
gonna have people in the upper deck are
they they're not gonna have a crowd like
they have for a Seahawks game and and if
that's how it's gonna be you got to find
smaller venues for these teams
I think so and I think that that should
be part of this lease plan and look year
or so ago I met with Oliver Luck and
listen to everything and look
everybody's plan sounds good and I hate
to say this but all these plans sound
good until you get hit in the jaw you
know or whatever the Mike Tyson thing is
but but to me I mean look at this
this when you look at the crowd in
Washington and look at those stadiums
look and I and and and I don't know what
any of these teams are gonna do but if I
were that New York team I'd be playing
in Red Bulls Stadium in Harrison New
Jersey it's a soccer stadium and it's
designed for a soccer crowd I don't know
25,000 those are the venues and I know
that this league wants to be big league
but you don't look big league when there
is what appears to be confetti in your
stadium those are the fans now as to the
store one last point I want to make
about the Stars or lack thereof I'm a
firm believer they should be attracting
guys from college football who aren't
eligible yet for the draft we know who
they are you identify the stars you pay
them a decent amount of money to come
play for you versus sticking around at
Clemson for one more year if you're
Trevor Lawrence and maybe that's part of
the plan once they get their feet under
them but I think that's a way to get
more people invested and interested in
there's gonna be a steady stream of guys
who establish themselves in the first
year or two of their college careers
that you can then pay real money now
what it would ultimately do is
completely disrupt the college system
and maybe get them to pay these guys to
fend off the XFL but I think that's a
potential path to success now regard
however long at last Peter right I mean
it may not last more than two years last
year the XF last time the XFL made it
one year last year the AAF imploded
during the opening season I'm always
looking for things that the NFL can
cherry-pick and the thing that I love is
the kickoff first of all it looks like
electric football when you've got 10
guys and 10 other guys five yards apart
just standing there until the return
catches the kick that is awesome but the
far better aspect of it is it takes the
high speed collision out of the kick off
which will reduce concussions and
serious neck injuries and I don't know
why the NFL hasn't pondered something
like this I love this yeah and what was
interesting about it Mike is that look
three or four years ago at a competition
committee press conference at the at the
NFL League meetings you know I forget I
think it was rich McKay and Troy Vincent
basically sounded the clarion call for
the kickoff in the NFL and they
basically said look if we continue to
have all these concussions on the kick
off we're getting rid of it and and I
mean it was very very clear and that was
the marching orders now concussions have
gone down they certainly have but I
don't know if I saw one kickoff this
year that I would consider to be
electrifying and so therefore and again
you don't I mean cordarrelle Patterson
is fun to watch the guy the Saints have
he's fun to watch he's a punt returner
mostly um but I just look at this and I
say it's common sense you know at some
point soon the kickoff is either gonna
go away totally or you're gonna do
something like this which I didn't even
know we've only seen it a few times now
and I don't know if it's the smartest
thing to do but I know that these are
the kind of ideas that the NFL should
look at to judge whether the kickoff has
a future in football the first XFL game
on Saturday afternoon the defenders
hosting the Dragons drew 3.3 million
average viewers on ABC last year the aaf
debut had 2.9 million on a Saturday
night on CBS so it's a little bit better
we'll see if it lasts Peter as you said
everyone has a plan until they get
punched in the face and the question is
will this be the next league to fade
into as Mike Tyson once said Bolivian
we'll find out over the coming weeks
months and years if the XFL can make it
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports